mountains here yeah yeah you know you
never had a problem with fame
celebrity thing success
of course i think
when you're an aggressive young man and
your entire life has been people say no
yes tough
no no you're never gonna make it you're
real you know
your mouth is crooked your voice is too
deep your eyes everything's wrong
and then you do make it what happens you
overreact
and now it's like i told you i'm just
i'm
not you you have too much pride too much
machismo too much everything yes because
you've been down
so long and you proved it so that's the
big danger
whereas you should be just humble be
quiet
but i didn't you know it's a good time
yeah
it was so now i've learned when i look
at my old interviews well what do you
think i want to get into a time machine
go back and punch myself
like rocky you're shut up
but you've always been this tough i mean
are you a tough guy
but um
yeah yeah yeah but since you were little
but not in the sense there are many men
much tougher than me real tough guys
okay
i think where i'm tough is is
interior-wise
yes really really tough because you have
to be
to succeed in the arts i'll bet you
that the greatest artist in the world
you'll never see
because they're so sensitive and the
rejection
so difficult they leave they quit they
go back home they become a farmer or
they become
whatever they get married so to be an
artist today when you see someone
successful on screen
you have to realize that person is tough
inside
because they took 20 years of rejection
rejection rejection
so now you see them that oh thank you
very much but inside they're like
yeah because you have to be how did you
overcome your insecurities and
i didn't you didn't no no i think
the insecurities that you're born with
you have your whole life
always that's it that's it
you know they're coming they say okay
i'm a little nervous there you go
go away go away like last night i'll go
onto a stage
in acapulco there's three four thousand
people
now my daughter's going she's scared
what are you thinking about nothing
inside of a boom boom
no it's nothing i said i go out there
these people are here to see me and i'm
happy to see them
and i'm gonna attack it and not
go oh thank you very much i said you are
you attack
and that's what i do so long as you play
games with their heads
because you know i tell you either but
then the head plays games with you
so always always always so it's a
constant battle
so you'll have some days where you just
feel so sorry for yourself
you feel so emotionally weak
and unworthy and insecure and then you
gotta go
okay this will pass
this is a moment everybody everybody
feels i don't care who it is
unless you're a sociopath
you have no conscience everyone i've
seen the most beautiful women in the
world i'm very insecure
oh you say one thing you go
you lost a little weight you know what
is it is it bad i mean
where where where i go and i go you know
yeah yeah and it saves it with guys i
don't care who it is
everybody has a button everyone
you just have to find it like always the
intellect